[Musique]
j'en doute
je ne viens viens de saint denis son
oeuvre sous le bras elle profite de ses
derniers jours pour rendre son tableau à
la direction de la culture et des sports
du département jc remanié plusieurs fois
bien sûr des retouches à faire mais
demandez-vous savoir car cet homme et ça
c'est le plus dur jour parce que parfois
dans des tons se sous-estiment mais je
trouve que l'action est belle par
rapport à la femme et sait mettre en
valeur peut-être là que bat dans chaque
femme ya peut-être une artiste qui
sommeille réceptionné par les agents du
département ces femmes artistes amateurs
laissent leurs créations toutes n'ont
pas le même lien la même histoire
un moment d'émotion au matin c'est quoi
cette histoire
non c'est une esclave qui à cause de ses
formes généreuses a été explosé comme un
animal devant ses maîtres et devant les
autres
je suis débutant dans la peinture et on
va dire je rêverais de me faire
connaître que j'ai donc les femmes
notamment de la réunion à s'accepter
pleinement dans les meilleurs estime
d'elle-même
donc le but voilà c'est de se
réconcilier avec ce que l'on est
vraiment profondément et de doter un peu
tous les artifices qui va bien souvent
ne nous embellissent pas forcément voulu
mettre en valeur la réunion le titre man
tableau c'est sensationnel et divine
dynamo en cabine
j'adore fin et jusqu'à maintenant
c'était dans le cadre de mon foyer ça
reste est vraiment tous les tableaux
étaient accrochés à la maison et là mes
enfants m'ont poussé m'ont dit maman et
c'est un petit coup et peintures
sculptures photographies relevant du
domaine des arts visuels sont les
matières imposer plus de 200 oeuvres
sont ainsi en liste cette année elles
sont toutes tout plein d'émotion au
moment de déposer leurs oeuvres parce
que c'est ça rappellent leur attachement
à cette qu'ils ont passé du temps à
confectionner donc c'est vraiment cessé
chaque année c'est pareil le prix
célimène est le plus ancien concours
culturels amateurs de la réunion un
engagement de la collectivité qui a
trouvé sa place dans le paysage culturel
c'est la chance donnée à des femmes
artistes amateurs dans le secret de
leurs ateliers qui n'ont jamais exposé
et qui n'osent pas montrer leur travail
célimène c'est la chance qui leur est
donnée de montrer pour la première fois
dans un très beau cadre avec une belle
scénographie ce travail qui n'est pas
connu invité les femmes à poser un acte
c'est leur donner du courage en même
temps toutes ces oeuvres seront exposées
pendant un mois à la villa du
département rue de paris à saint-denis
et c'est tout naturellement le 8 mars
que sera décerné le prix célimène 2017
[Musique]